Well, you guys seemd to enjoy our recent superhero
facts video, so here we are with a second
installment in quick succession!
These days, the popularity of superheroes
is such that a lot of people think they know
everything there is to know about their favourite
bad guy-battling champions - but they couldn't
be more wrong.
The history of comic books is so long and
rich that there are bound to be facts that
have passed them by, slipped their mind, or
some that they have misconceived, so this
video aims to educate the masses regarding
some of those facts.
We hope you enjoy it!
And make sure you subscribe to our channel
join the notification squad to receive alerts
every time we upload something new!
Here are ten superhero facts that never crossed
your mind: Part 2.
Star-Lord Has Amassed More Than 350,000 Murders
Most casual comic book movie fans hadn't even
heard of Peter Quill AKA Star-Lord before
2014's Guardians of the Galaxy movie was released.
He was a C-list superhero from an obscure
comic book title.
Now, thanks to Chris Pratt's epic portrayal
of him in said movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, he's hugely popular and a hero to
millions.
Granted, he's a mischievous outlaw in the
movies, but he's generally a nice guy whose
goodness totally shone through in the end.
However, in the comic books, he's actually
a mass murderer.
In fact, Star-Lord is known to have amassed
more than 350,000 murders in the comics - that
is according to the Nova Corps' records - which
makes him one of the most prolific killers
in all of Marvel!
Daredevil Influenced The Creation Of The Ninja
Turtles
Daredevil is currently one of Marvel's most
popular heroes, thanks to his fantastic Netflix
series, in which Charlie Cox brilliantly portrays
the Hell's Kitchen vigilante.
That series has to be one of the high points
of the character's history - but it pales
into insignificance when you realise that
Daredevil was the main inspiration behind
the creation of none other than the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles!
When Kevin Eastman and Peter Laird created
the reptilian quartet, they took inspiration
the style of Frank Miller's iconic Daredevil
run.
They also made the Turtles' origin story mirror
that of the Man Without Fear's, which depicted
a young boy saving an old man and being blinded
by radioactive chemicals.
Their sensei Splinter was named after Daredevil's
mentor Stick, and the Turtles' main foes - The
Foot Clan - were inspired by Daredevil enemies
The Hand.
A team-up between the two entities would be
awesome, therefore but, sadly, inter-company
politics have made that impossible up to now.
Supergirl's First Boyfriend Was Her Pet Horse
We mentioned in our previous superhero facts
video that Aquaman's first love was a dolphin,
but we think we can beat that with this weird
fact - Supergirl's first boyfriend was her
pet horse!
The 1960s seemed to take a She-Ra-esque camp
approach to Supergirl's storytelling - and
that was never more evident than when her
superpowered horse, Comet, appeared.
Comet ended up receiving a human form - "Bronco"
Bill Starr - and Supergirl actually embarked
on a romantic relationship with him.
The weird thing was that he was only able
to assume this form when a certain comet passed
the Earth - meaning that, for the majority
of the time, he was indeed still a horse.
Thankfully, as the 60s came to a close, this
kind of sugar-coated weirdness petered out
with it.
The Silver Surfer Has Citizenship In 190+
Countries
The Silver Surfer is an extraterrestrial superhero
hailing from the planet Zenn-La.
Although Earth is very familiar to him - and
indeed the people of Earth in the Marvel universe
are very familiar with him - he certainly
isn't a native of the planet.
It should come as a surprise to you, therefore,
to learn that he actually has citizenship
in more than 190 of Earth's countries.
The Surfer did, of course, earn his citizenships
by saving the planet on more than one occasion.
The one time he saved the Earth from having
all of its culture removed and replaced by
his native race is the one that stood out
to several UN representatives.
They decided to give him citizenship to their
countries - which included China, France and
Russia to name a few.
He was subsequently given citizenship to the
rest of the planet's countries - which is
more than any actual Earthling can say.
Green Lantern's Powers Were Inspired By Aladdin
When you think of all the characters that
came before him in fiction - Superman, Buck
Rogers, Captain Nemo and many others - one
of the last you would ever think of as having
influenced the creation of Green Lantern is
Aladdin.
However, it was indeed the main character
of the Middle Eastern folk tale - on of the
"Arabian Nights" stories - that inspired the
creation of Alan Scott, DC's first Green Lantern.
When you think about it, it's not actually
that strange either.
Aladdin got anything he wanted from the genie
of the lamp - very much like the constructs
Green Lantern Corps members can will into
existence.
Moreover, Scott was very nearly named "Alan
Ladd" as a homage to Aladdin.
However, it was decided that "Ladd" would
be his middle name - which was probably for
the best, in retrospect!
Hawkeye Was Originally A Villain
Hawkeye is, in every sense of the word, a
hero.
Although he wasn't a founding member of the
Avengers, he was the second character - after
Captain America - to join the original team,
and he has been a mainstay in the lineup for
most of the subsequent 60+ years since then.
He's brave, incredibly skilled, and fights
against superpowered foes in spite of the
fact that he has no superhuman abilities of
his own.
However, when he first appeared on-panel in
a 1964 issue of Tales of Suspense, Clint Barton
was presented as an enemy of Iron Man's.
Although he was more confused than malicious,
he was still a villain, and it took him around
nine months to pledge his alliance to the
side of good.
So, next time you watch 2012's The Avengers
and see Hawkeye as a mind-controlled bad guy
for the bulk of it, don't forget that that's
exactly how the character was originally intended
to be.
Doctor Strange Was Based On A Character From
A Radio Show
The Sorcerer Supreme, Doctor Strange, was,
of course, created by the iconic pairing of
artist and writer Steve Ditko and Marvel legend
Stan Lee.
Lee has actually admitted that Strange was
initially Ditko's idea, but says that he had
a lot of creative input and responsibility
with regards to the character's overall conception.
It has since been revealed by Lee that their
character was heavily based on a little known
character called Chandu the Magician - the
star of a humble radio program that aired
on the Mutual Broadcasting System in the 1930s.
The program also went on to become a film
in 1932 - just like Doctor Strange did in
2016 - and was about a man who was both a
magician and a secret agent.
You Can Study Batman At College
There was a time when the entire concept of
superheroes was largely seen as a guilty pleasure
by those who enjoyed it.
People who liked superheroes and the comic
books they appeared in were often mocked.
Comics weren't taken seriously as a medium
and superheroes as a genre were seen as silly.
But it's not like that these days - in fact,
you can actually study Batman at college!
No, really, there's a genuine college course
called "The Science of Batman" at the University
of Victoria in Canada.
When you think about it, there are actually
many aspects of the Dark Knight that could
be studied - mainly of the psychological variety
- but this course actually focuses on the
physical side of the character.
The course description reads "The extreme
range of adaptability of the human body explored
through the life of the Caped Crusader."
Deadpool's Healing Factor Is His Only Superhuman
Ability
Deadpool is so enormously popular these days
- thanks in no small part to Ryan Reynolds'
brilliant portrayal of the character in his
2016 titular movie - that his fans are often
in denial about the level he's at on the power
ladder.
Claims that he could beat the likes of Superman
and the Hulk in a straight-up fight are often
made - but they're ridiculous.
Why?
Because Deadpool's only power is his superhuman
regenerative healing factor.
Deadpool isn't super-strong, he's not super-fast,
he can still feel pain like the rest of us
and, aside from occasionally having a teleporter
in his possession, his weapons and gardgets
are largely underwhelming.
He's basically a peak human who recovers from
injury insanely quick.
That's it.
So, still think he has a chance against a
lightspeed Kryptonian who can bench press
planets, fly, fire heat rays as hot as the
sun, AND heal faster than the average human
like Deadpool himself can?
Think again.
Oh and that horrible character in 2009's X-Men
Origins: Wolverine - that just wasn't Deadpool.
Captain America Live In An Alternate Dimension
For More Than A Decade
Captain America has been a staple part of
the 616 Marvel universe's Earth since he first
appeared on-panel in 1941.
It's hard to imagine that timeline without
him in it, but the truth is he has actually
spent a whopping twelve years away from it
- by virtue of the fact that that's how long
he was trapped in another dimension on one
occasion.
Arnim Zola abducted him and trapped him in
the post-apocalyptic hellscape dimension known
as Dimension Z.
Cap was stuck there for ten issues which,
as previously mentioned, spanned twelve years.
However, to his allies back in his world,
it had only been a few minutes - and they
barely realised he'd gone missing.
That's got to be tough to take!
In that time, Cap had been through all manner
of experiences - including raising a young
boy - until he was brought home by writer
Rick Remender in 2013's Captain America #10.
Thanks for watching our video about ten more
superhero facts that never crossed your mind.
What other great superhero facts do you know?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.